bonjour
aujourd'hui on va
de la novlangue
leterme ii
hong a été inventé par l'écrivain george
orwell dans son roman 1984
c'est un terme qui est redevenu à la
mode depuis quelques temps notamment
pour désigner un certain jargon politico
médiatique
et la novlangue ou le novlangue tout
dépend des traductions
ça désigne un langage ça désigne un mode
d'expression
pour but de nous empêcher de formuler
certaines idées
et donc par votre conséquences
de nous empêcher de concevoir certaines
idées
la novlangue
c'est une transformation de la langue
une transformation des mots et de la
grammaire
destiné à rendre impossible toute pensée
subversive
le postulat de la novlangue c'est que
nous pensons d'abord à partir de mots
c'est que les mots qu'on emploie
détermine notre pensée
et que donc plus le langage est
appauvrie
plus la pensée qui en découlent sera
elle-même appauvri
en d'autres termes
appauvrissait la langue
vous rendrez impossible toute pensée
contestataires
va donc y avoir beaucoup de choses à
dire sur cette novlangue tant sur le
plan linguistique que sur le plan
politique et philosophique
mais avant d'analyser ça quelques mots
sur le contexte
1984 c'est un roman écrit par orwell en
d'ailleurs le choix de cette date 1984
vient de l'inversion des deux derniers
chiffres de son année d'écriture 48
c'est donc ce qu'on appelle un roman
d'anticipation
est ce qu'à voulu décrire orwell dans
c'est une société totalitaire
tali terre au sens moderne c'est-à-dire
qui régit la totalité des comportements
qui régit la totalité non seulement des
actions des individus
mais aussi et plus fondamentalement
encore
de leur pensée
un régime tali terre ce n'est pas un
régime qui contraint seulement les corps
c'est un régime qui contraint les
esprits
parce que dès lors qu'on domine les
esprits il n'y a plus besoin de dominer
les corps
partant du principe que nos actions sont
le résultats sont la conséquence de nos
pensées
en influençant les pensées on
n'influence les actions
ont les influences à la source
c'est ce que marx appelait l'aliénation
la dépossession de nos consciences
l'expropriation de nos consciences
et donc croire que le total charisme se
caractériserait par le recours à la
force
passé complètement à côté de l'essence
du totalitarisme à savoir le contrôle
des esprits
quand on contrôle les esprits on n'a
plus besoin de contrôler les corps
on peut laisser les individus agir
librement pour ainsi dire
puisque les laisser agir c'est les
laisser accomplir ce qu'on aura
introduit dans leur esprit
dans un régime totalitaire abouti dans
un régime totalitaire matures
la contrainte physique n'a pas lieu
d'être
carla contre physique signifie qu'on n'a
pas correctement manipulés les esprits
je vous renvoie un bon épisode sur
edward bernays hills comment manipuler
l'opinion
daley ce qui montre bien qu'en matière
de domination la manipulation des
esprits est infiniment plus efficace que
n'importe quelle pression physique
cain vous menace physiquement
vous ne pouvez pas ignorer qu'il vous
menace
sentait la contrainte s'exercer sur vous
un pistolet sur la tempe
message clair
alors que la manipulation mentale ou en
tout cas la manipulation mentale réussi
là c'est beaucoup plus difficile à
détecter
parce que la manipulation mentale joue
sur des ressorts intellectuelle sur des
ressorts émotionnels c'est à dire sur
des ressorts intérieurs
la contrainte physique est extérieur
donc visible
tandis que la manipulation mentale est
intérieure donc invisible
quand on est sous l'emprise d'une
manipulation mentale
se rend pas compte qu'on est sous
l'emprise d'une manipulation
finition
c'est toujours après coup c'est à dire
quand on est sorti quand on sent des
libérés
on peut dire qu'on était manipulé
jamais pendant
et c'est pour ça qu'ils doivent
d'analysé que la démocratie était
paradoxalement le régime le plus adapté
à la domination des masses
parce que c'est le régime le plus adapté
à la manipulation de l'opinion
mocratie pas besoin armée
l'information suffit
l'information la publicité l'idéologie
tous qui oeuvre à la conformation des
esprits
tout ce qu'ils oeuvrent à la paix reçue
à non
parce que quand on est convaincu d'une
idée on n'a pas besoin de nous l'imposer
impose nous mêmes
et donc le mot d'ordre de la propagande
moderne c'est la liberté
la liberté de s'imposer soi même un mode
de pensée conçue comme provenant de
l'intérieur
mais trouvant son origine réelle dans un
conditionnement extérieur
c'est de la propagande
la conviction
la conviction d'être le maître de nos
pensées être le capitaine de nos pensées
sans voir que dans un autre contexte
idéologique
ans et n'aurait pas du tout été les
mêmes
remarquez comme dans nos démocraties
modernes on est adepte du penser par soi
même
mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire penser
par soi même
on pense pour à partir de quelque chose
on pense toujours à partir d'une matière
première d'une matière idéologique
première
or cette matière première on ne la
choisit pas
on la reçoit
et le langage c'est la première des
matières premières de notre pensée
le langage c ce qui structure notre
pensée au delà du contenu de notre
pensée
et bien la novlangue c'est
l'intervention du langage dans les
prémices de notre pensée
dans les murs porteurs de notre pensée
et comprendre ça c'est comprendre en
quoi comme le disait windstein
les limites notre longue
sont les limites de notre monde
donc pour
1984 c'est l'histoire d'un homme ou une
stone smith qui vit à londres
sur le territoire dgt océaniens
l'un des trois grands blocs territoriaux
avec eurasia et east asia et le métier
de winston ses
employés du ministère de la vérité
donc évidemment il ya un côté
volontairement ironique et caricatural
dans cette appellation
ministère de la vérité
mais après tout il ne faut pas oublier
qu'à l'époque de l'urss
le journal d'information officiel du
parti communiste s'appelait la pravda
ce qui signifie la vérité
et d'ailleurs de nos jours les grands
journaux possède bien leur cellule de
fact checking c'est à dire
de vérification des faits
donc revendiquer le monopole de la
vérité quand on est le pouvoir c'est un
peu le b à ba
donc winston officie au commissariat des
archives historiques de océaniens
et son travail consiste à manipuler ces
archives de sorte à les faire
correspondre à la ligne officielle de
languedoc
qui est le parti officiel d'oceania
donc il va détruire des documents
compromettants
où il va au contraire fabriquer des
documents dans le sens des intérêts du
parti
selon l'idh est bien connu que
qui contrôle le passé contrôle l'avenir
qui contrôle les mémoires
contre les volontés
c'est quelque chose a été largement
étudié le rapport au passé
fluence du rapport au passé dans les
opinions du présent
et la manipulation des faits historiques
l'un des moyens les plus efficaces
d'ancrer dans les esprits l'idéologie
qui servira le mieux les intérêts du
pouvoir
mais le problème avec winston c'est
qu'il a conscience qu'en travaillant
pour les intérêts du parti
il travaille contre les intérêts de la
vérité
en d'autres termes ce qui se posent à
lui c'est un cas de conscience
parce qu'il sait que s'il affiche son
scepticisme à l'égard du parti son
scepticisme à l'égard des mensonges
prétendument bienveillant du parti
ils risquent l'arrestation par la police
de la pensée
police de la pensée qui traquent ce
qu'orwell appelle les crimes de penser
bien ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure à
savoir que l'état totalitaire moderne et
celui qui a déplacé l'objet de la
répression du corps à l'esprit
de l'action à la conscience
en d'autres termes l'état
r n'est pas celui qui va empêcher l'acte
subversif
l'état totalitaire et celui qui veut
empêcher la possibilité de l'acte
subversif
voyez la différence
parce que dès lors qu'il existe une
possibilité que le pouvoir soit menacé
il existe une probabilité c'est à dire
un risque qu'il soit menacé
et un pouvoir digne de ce nom ne prend
pas de risque avec les menaces
c'est pourquoi du point de vue de
languedoc la notion de crime de penser
ou de police de la pensée n'a rien de
choquant
parce qu'un crime commence par l'idée du
crime
remarquer que dans nos sociétés il
existe ce qu'on appelle le délit
d'opinion
d'ailleurs le terme est assez mal
choisie parce qu'en réalité le délit
d'opinion concerne l'expression de
certaines opinions et non ses opinions à
proprement parler
s'il existait une technologie
de savoir ce que l'on pense sans l'avoir
exprimé
les technologies capables littéralement
de lire dans nos pensées
la question se pose de savoir ce qu'il
adviendrait de ceux qui ont des opinions
interdite
ce n'est pas pour rien qu'on a forgé
l'expression de terrorisme intellectuel
le terrorisme intellectuel
c'est l'ensemble des procédés qui vise
dans un premier temps à réprimer
l'expression de certaines idées
et dans un deuxième temps à réprimer
jusqu'à la conception de ses idées
c'est
quai de criminaliser la pensée
il suffit d'en criminaliser l'expression
et l'éviction social se chargera de nous
en faire avoir honte
donc c'est ce petit jeu-là queenstown
refuse de se plier
et ce n'est évidemment pas si orwell a
choisi de faire de son personnage un
employé des archives historiques
parce que ça signifie que les pensées
auquel winston doit se soumettre porte
sur des faits
or un fait cet objectif
là signifie qu sion et l'interprétation
d'un fait c'est subjectif
mais le fait en lui-même cet objectif
donc quelqu'un qui a une conscience qui
fonctionne c'est quelqu'un qui ne peut
pas ignorer quand et façon un fait
d'histoire
ou un inventant un fait qu'il n'a jamais
eu lieu
il ment
il ment et il sait qu'ils m'ont
et c'est cette conscience
provoquera sa perte
et donc c'est la con ve la novlangue à
savoir que pour éviter ce genre de
situation
ce genre de situation où la distinction
entre la vérité et le mensonge a encore
un sens
cette situation où le langage permet
encore de différencier une chose et son
contraire
et donc potentiellement d'exprimer une
critique à l'égard du pouvoir
faut effacer
jusqu'à la possibilité d'une telle
critique
autrement dit effacés non pas seulement
des faits non pas seulement des
informations
mais effacé des idées
effacés
dépenser
est le meilleur moyen d'effacer dépenser
c'est les mots qui permettent d'exprimer
cette pensée
alors concrètement comment la novlangue
fonctionne-t-elle
sonne sur deux principes
son et la dissonance
commençons par l'arrêt du chaud
la réduction ça veut dire que la
novlangue se caractérise par la
suppression de certains mots jugés
inutiles
en supprimant des mots donc en réduisant
l'étendue du vocabulaire
on induit un appauvrissement de la
pensée
ça c'est quelque chose de très important
à comprendre sur le plan si colin
christique
à savoir que nos idées sont dépendantes
des mots qu'on utilise
et pendant que c'est à dire comme on
disait tout à l'heure
qu'on pense à partir de mots
les mots sont la matière de notre pensée
et donc moins on a deux mots pour
s'exprimer
- on à d'outils pour penser
na dem au moins il est possible de
construire des raisonnements complexes
ou des raisonnements nuancé
à voir du haut r ce n'est pas seulement
pouvoir frimer devant ceux qui en ont
moins
c'est d'abord être en mesure de désigner
précisément les choses
de renseigner précisément
cinq mille mots c'est le nombre moyen de
mots utilisés par un français
sachant que l'ong française comporte
environ
en mille mots
donc on utilise à peu près 5% du lexique
disponibles
et ce qui est à c'est que pour les
informations strictement pratique
300 mots suffisent
donc moins on a de vocabulaire
disponibles - on est en mesure d'aller
vers l'abstraction
et sans abstraction sans capacité
spéculative on ne peut pas penser le
monde
penser le monde au sens de penser au
delà de la simple désignation des choses
concrètes
le concept même de pouvoir nous pouvoir
au sens de pouvoir politique
ça implique une capacité d'abstraction
parce que le pouvoir ce n'est pas une
entité physique
l'état n'est pas une entité physique
la liberté n'est pas une entité physique
pourtant ce sont des concepts
fondamentaux
et concepts indispensable même pour
pouvoir penser notre condition
donc moins on dispose de mots
plus le pouvoir est tranquille
croire que le pouvoir chercherait à ras
bord is et l'élitisme intellectuelle ou
l'élitisme scolaire
s'est passé complètement à côté des
mécanismes réels de la domination des
masses à savoir la déculturation
ce que jean claude michéa lui-même
disciples d'orwell
appelée l'enseignement de l'ignorance
en appauvrissant la langue
on appauvrit l'esprit critique
on appauvrit nos moyens de production
critique
donc la neuve angle ça consiste à
expurger des dictionnaires tous les mots
qui traduisent une nuance
tous les mots qui traduisent une
subtilité
ou du moins ce que le pouvoir considère
à être une subtilité
on va prendre un exemple qu'on trouve
dans 1984 le mot excellent
dans la novlangue le mot excellent
existe pas
pourquoi
parce que excellent c'est une
amplification de l'adjectif bon
donc dans la novlangue au lieu de dire
qu'une chose est excellente
à calais
double plus bonne
au lieu de dire qu'une chose est
mauvaise on dira qu'elle est un bonne
un étang le préfixe au privatif
autrement dit l'expression de la nuance
ne passe plus par des mots différents
elle passe par des préfixes de
quantification
plus ou moins
double plus ou double -
donc par là
sion et la mécanisation des opérations
d'un moustique
c'est sans le principe de réduction
rires le langage
appauvrir les possibilités de
combinaisons lexical
sorte à produire une pensée
structurellement incapable de désigner
certaines réalités
et ça c'est très simple comprendre parce
qu'aujourd'hui on entend parfois l'idée
que l'appauvrissement du langage ne
serait pas si grave que ça
que finalement étant donné qu'on peut
fonctionner sur le plan pratique avec
quelques centaines de mots il faudrait
arrêter de vouloir à tout prix que les
jeunes et du vocabulaire
que c'est pas si important de faire des
fautes de grammaire
bref qu'il faudrait arrêter de
fétichiser la langue
eh bien
dépend de ce qu'on veut
si on se fiche d'avoir des outils pour
mieux penser le monde
si on voit le langage
comme la simple émission de signaux
sonores comme chez les baleines
oui à ce moment là on n'a pas besoin
d'avoir un répertoire de 60 mille mots
estime
linguistique
à penser la réalité et à penser notre
condition
alors là le problème a du sens
est ce que montre orwell c'est justement
que la prison du langage pauvres est une
prison sans clé
parce que pour voir la pauvreté du
langage comme un problème
il faudrait posséder le langage
permettant de voir en quoi c'est un
problème
donc on n'en sort pas
littéralement
celui qu il pas les outils pour penser
sa propre domination est condamné à ne
jamais être consciente sa domination
c'est une tautologie
en d'autres termes en privant les
individus de leurs outils d'analysé
d'interprétation du monde
sûr qu'ils ne soient jamais en position
qu'il n'est même jamais la volonté
s'opposer à quelque pouvoir que ce soit
comment
opposé à un pouvoir si on n'est même pas
conscients que ce pouvoir existe
à pour le langage s'est tué dans la
conscience des hommes
penser qu'ils auraient pu faire naître
dans leur coeur leur désir d'être libre
pas de désir de liberté sans conscience
de notre asservissement
et pas de conscience notre
asservissement
sans mots pour exprimer l'asservissement
je citais total la phrase de windstein
les limites de notre langue
sont les limites de notre monde
de notre monde c'est à dire de notre
monde mental
notre univers mental
or ce que nous appelons la réalité
cela n'est rien d'autre que la réalité
perçue et pensé par l'individu
on aura beau vous dire qu'en réalité le
ciel et rouge
vous continuerez à le percevoir comme
étant bleu
et bien là son si vous n'aviez jamais
entendu parler de liberté
vous ne sauriez pas ce qu'être libre
veut dire
d'ailleurs dans 1984 le mot libre n'a
plus du tout la même signification
libre ne veut plus dire émancipé ou
indépendants mais inoccupés
comme dans la phrase la voie est libre
donc quand de réduction du langage
s'inclut également l'élimination des
significations secondaire et figurez
vous savez que le français est très
riche en sens figuré
d'ailleurs dire que le français est
riche c'est déjà parlé au sens figuré
bien si vous éliminez les significations
secondaire et métaphorique
vous supprimez non seulement des
possibilités d'expression
mais vous supprimez également toutes les
relations analogique
tout ce qui fait que vous pouvez établir
des relations des comparaisons et des
parallèles entre les choses
on en revient à l'idée que sans
l'abstraction il y à tout un pan de la
réalité qui échappe à notre champ de
conscience
tout ce qui relève du spirituel et une
métaphysique d'une part
mais aussi
qui relèvent du politique
si le mot libre se réduit à son sens
courant dean occupée ça veut dire que
vous pouvez vivre toute votre existence
sans ne serait ce que vous posez la
question de votre liberté
un monde dans lequel le concept de
liberté n'existe pas c'est un monde dans
lequel les esclavages ne posera jamais
eu aucun problème
car pour que l' esclavage pose un
problème il faut le juger à l'aune d'un
critère métaphysico politique
c'est-à-dire à l'aune d'un critère
abstrait à savoir le critère de la
liberté
donc sans concept de liberté pas de
concept d' esclavage
donc pas de possibilité de penser les
esclavages et donc pas de possibilité de
s'opposer à l' esclavage
le mot renferme l'idée
et donc c'est là qu'on en a yves au
deuxième principe de la novlangue après
le principe de réduction
le principe de dissonances
dans 1984
il y à un principe qui régit la vie des
citoyens
s'appelle la double pensée
la double pensée c'est le fait que deux
propositions qui s'opposent
c'est vrai en même temps
connaissez la fameuse phrase d'ablettes
être ou ne pas être
viendront angle ce serait plutôt être et
ne pas être
être et ne pas être
simultanément c'est impossible
logiquement impossible
parce que les deux propositions c'est
exclu
de même qu'on ne peut pas simultanément
monter et descendre ou être réveillé et
dormir
eh bien demain 84 c'est possible
c'est possible c'est à dire que le
langage admet que l'on puisse soutenir
simultanément deux propositions
contradictoires
on retrouve ça dans les slogans du parti
que vous avez sans doute déjà entendu
la guerre c'est la paix
liberté c'est l'esclavagé
l'ignorance c'est la force
autrement dit dans la lang l'idée de
contrat dit si on logique
n'existe pas
et si l'idée de contradiction logique
alors il n'y a plus de vrais nids de
faux
si bien substituer à une proposition la
proposition inverse sans que cela ne
pose de problème à la conscience
si le pouvoir une chose un jour
et qu'ils affirment le contraire le
lendemain
aucun problème
aucun problème parce que l'incohérence
n'est pas un problème
parce que l'incohérence
n'existe même pas
quand on crie voir l'un des éléments les
plus probants sur lequel on peut
s'appuyer
ce sont ces incohérences
parce que l'incohérence affaiblit la
confiance
donc elle affaiblit l'adhésion
si le pouvoir de faire une chose et son
contraire
sans que ce soit perçu comme une
incohérence
dans ce cas là pas il se fonde la
confiance
alors oui ça paraît ange parce que nous
on vit encore dans un monde dans lequel
la notion de contradictions a un sens
c'est à dire que la logique est pour
nous un élément structurant
un élément qui permet de dire que les
choses ont du sens
mais dans une
tall eater
le sens n'est pas nécessaire
aux contres même le sens est un obstacle
c'est un obstacle à l'obéissance aveugle
le vrai pouvoir c'est celui qui peut
s'émanciper de tout y compris de ses
propres contraintes
le vrai pouvoir c'est celui qui peut
désobéir à ses propres injonction
parce qu en s'émancipant de ses propres
contraintes le pouvoir prouve son
caractère absolu
la cohérence n'est un problème que pour
ceux qui font de la logique une
contrainte à laquelle on doit se
soumettre
en refusant de se soumettre à la logique
le pouvoir montre qu'il est le pouvoir
et ce faisant il apparaît comme plus
puissant encore
on craint d'autant plus la force qu'il
se contraint pas
donc la double pensée c'est la
dissolution de la logique élémentaire
de la logique fondée sur la distinction
du vrai et du faux
iran impossible là encore toute
production d'un discours critique et
subversif
puisque pour que ce discours critique
soit valable et cohérent
encore faut-il que la notion de
cohérence est un sens
si tout est vrai et faux en même temps
comment un discours critique aurait-il
plus de valeur et de pertinence que le
discours qui affirment le contraire
donc avec le penser la dissonance
cognitive n'est pas un problème
puisque la dissonance est le principe
même
cette dissonance ne peut conduire qu'à
l'inconsistance
celui qui peut accepter deux choses
logiquement contradictoires
n'aura jamais aucune raison de se battre
pour l'une d'entre elles
bat pour une cause
on prend les armes pour une cause
à partir du moment on considère que
cette cause est juste
quelle est la cause juste
mais si tout à coup
on estime qu'une cause est tout aussi
juste que la cause contraire
pourquoi il répond se battre pour l'une
plutôt que pour l'autre
la double pensée est un paradis on de la
contestation
donc vous le voyez la neuve j à
plusieurs niveaux
par le principe de réduction elle agit
sur la conscience des individus
en rendant impossible la formation de
certaines idées
la conceptualisations de certaines idées
donc la possibilité même de toute
critique du pouvoir
revendication de liberté
et
cible de dissonances
jce sur le comportement des individus
rendant absurde
un jugement en faveur d'une cause
que toutes causes qui apparaît juste
peut simultanément à paraître injuste
la novlangue celle instrument de
domination ultime
puisque c'est l'instrument de domination
qui se fait oublier comme instrument de
domination
qui pénètre dans la conscience de l'être
humain
jusqu'à effacer son âme
le souvenir même de sa liberté
je cite
la novlangue a été la langue officielle
de l'oceania elle fut inventée pour
répondre aux besoins de languedoc ou
socialisme anglais en en 1984 la
novlangue n'était pas la seule langue en
usage que ce fût oralement ou par écrit
les articles de fond du times était
écrit en novlangue mais c'était un tour
de force qui ne pouvait être réalisé que
par des spécialistes
on comptait que la novlangue aurait
finalement supplanté lancy langues nous
dirions la langue ordinaire vers l'année
2050 le but de la novlangue était non
seulement de fournir un mode
d'expression aux idées générales et aux
habitudes mentales des dévots de
languedoc mais de rendre impossible tout
autre mode de pensée il était entendu
que lorsque la novlangue serait une fois
pour toutes adopté et que l'anssi langue
serait oublier une idée hérétiques c'est
à dire une idée s'écartant des principes
de languedoc serait littéralement
impensable
du moins dans la mesure où la pensée
dépend des mots le vocabulaire de la
novlangue était construit de telle sorte
qu il pu fournir une expression exact
est souvent très nuancée aux idées qu'un
membre du parti pouvait à juste titre
désiré communiqué mais il excluait
toutes les autres idées et même les
possibilités d'y arriver par des
méthodes indirectes l'invention de mots
nouveaux l'élimination surtout des mots
indésirables la suppression dans les
mots restant de toute signification
secondaire qu'elle qu'elle fût contribué
à ce résultat
ainsi le mot libre existait encore en
novlangue mais ne pouvait être employé
que dans des phrases comme le chemin est
libre il ne pouvait être employé dans le
sens ancien de libertés politiques ou de
liberté intellectuelle les libertés
politiques et intellectuelles n'existait
en effet plus même sous forme de concept
elle n'avait donc nécessairement pas de
nom
en dehors du désir de supprimer les mots
dont le sens n'était pas orthodoxe
l'appauvrissement du vocabulaire était
considérée comme une fin en soi et on ne
laisser subsister aucun mot dont on
pouvait se passer la novlangue était
destinée non à étendre mais a diminué le
domaine de la pensée et la réduction au
minimum du choix des mots aider
indirectement à atteindre ce but on voit
par ce qui précède quand novlangue
l'expression des opinions non orthodoxes
était presque impossible au dessus d'un
niveau très bas on pouvait naturellement
émettre des hérésies grossières les
sortes de blasphème il était possible
par exemple de dire big brother est un
bon mais cette constatation qui pour une
oreille orthodoxe n'exprimer qu une
absurdité évidente par elle même
n'aurait pu être soutenus par une
argumentation raisonnée car les mots
nécessaires manquaient les idées contre
languedoc ne pouvait être conservée que
sous une forme vague inexprimable en
mots et ne pouvait être nommé qu'en
termes très généraux qui formaient bloc
et condamné des groupes entiers
d'hérésie sans pour cela les définir on
ne pouvait en fait se servir de la
novlangue dans un but non orthodoxes que
par une traduction inexacte des mots
novlangue en en six langues par exemple
la phrase tous les hommes sont égaux
était correct en neuf langues mais dans
la même proportion que la phrase tous
les hommes sont roux serait possible en
ont six langues elle ne contenait pas
d'erreurs grammaticales mais exprimer
une erreur palpable à savoir que tous
les hommes seraient égaux en taille en
poids et en force en 1984 quand lancy
langue était encore un mode normal
d'expression le danger théorique
existait qu en employant des mots
novlangue ont pu se souvenir de leur
sens primitif en pratique il n'était pas
difficile en s'appuyant solidement sur
la double pensée d'éviter cette
confusion toutefois la possibilité même
d'une telle erreur aurait disparu avant
deux générations une personne dont
l'éducation aurait été faite en neuf
langues seulement ne serait pas
davantage que égale avait un moment eu
le sens secondaire de politiquement égal
ou que libre avait un moment signifier
libre politiquement que par exemple une
personne qui n'aurait jamais entendu
parler d'échec ne connaîtrai leçon
spéciale attaché à rennes et à tour il y
aurait beaucoup de crimes et d'erreurs
qu'il serait hors de son pouvoir de
commettre simplement parce qu'il n'avait
pas de nom et était par conséquent
inimaginable
et l'on pouvait prévoir qu'avec le temps
les caractéristiques spéciales de la
novlangue deviendrait de plus en plus
prononcée car le nombre des mots
diminuerait de plus en plus le sens
serait de plus en plus rigides et la
possibilité d' une impropriété de termes
diminuerait constamment lorsque lens il
encore est une fois pour toute et est
supplanté le dernier lien avec le passé
serait tranchée
l'histoire était écrite mais des
fragments de la littérature du passé
survivre et ça et là a parfaitement
censuré et aussi longtemps que l'on
garde elle en six langues il était
possible de les lire mais de tel
fragment même si par hasard ils
survivaient serait plus tard
inintelligible est intraduisible
si la domination
on était quelque chose de facile à
détecter
elle ne serait pas la domination
dénoncer la violence du pouvoir
dénoncer
tu es de l'étang
c'est une chose
ça
voir que pour l'essentiel
le véritable organe de la domination est
en nous
comme dirait labo ici les tyrans ne sont
grands que parce que nous sommes à
genoux
sommes à genoux
que parce que nous consentons à l'être
nous le sommes deux m
parce que nous consentons
à obéir
ce n'est pas
heures qui nous pousse à obéir
c'est aussi notre conditionnement
car quand nous sommes conditionnés à
obéir
nous n'avons pas l'impression d' obéir
l'impression de choisir
et le langage est l'un des premiers
outils de notre conditionnement
parce que les mots pénètre jusque dans
les portes de notre conscience
faire consentir à ce que d'autres mots
ne seraient pas parvenus
à nous faire accepter
trouvez les mots et vous n'aurez plus
besoin d'eux g
trouver les mots qui fonctionnent
les mots qui vise juste
et vous voilà m
chance d'autrui
si winston a désobéi
parce que quelque chose en lui
fort que les mots
plus forts que la pensée
que le mental
un au delà mou qui vient des profondeurs
de l'être
or de l'âme
et qui lorsqu'on tend l'oreille
murmura votre coeur
quel chemin suivre
je vous remercie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]